[Music]
act 1 enter Gower before the palace of
Antioch and this is what counter says to
sing a song that old was sung from ashes
ancient gala has come
assuming man's infirmities to grab your
ear and please your hearts so apparently
I should have said Inferno towers to run
that it has been song at festivals and
amber amber eaves and holy airs and
lords and ladies in their lives have
read it while restoratives the purchase
is to make men glorious and then there's
a sentence in Latin and then if you born
in these latter times when it's more
ripe accept my rhymes and that to hear
an old man sing may to your wishes
pleasure bring my life would wish than
ever might waste it for you like tapir
light this Antioch then Antiochus the
Great built up this city for his
cheapest seat sate the fairest in all
Syria I tell you what man offers say
this king unto him took affair who died
and left a female heir for buxom blithe
and full of face as heaven had lent her
all his grace the whom the father
lacking took and her to incest deed
provoked it says prevent bad child worse
father to entice his own to evil should
be done by none but custom what they did
begin with was with long use account no
sin the beauty of the sinful Dame made
many princes through the frame to seek
her as a bed fellow in marriage
pleasures play fellow now I have a
problem with this he's rhyming fellow
with fellow which our Thorin brother
I mean he's Shakespeare you think that
which to prevent he made a law to keep
her still and men in all that who saw
asked her for his wife his real told
Knox lost his wife so for her many are
white did die as yon grim looks do
testify what now ensues to the judgment
of your eye I give my cause the best can
justify
now that's just the opening monologue
cuz I think I'm a pig disappointed
because now it says scene one that
wasn't even part of scene one I don't
know what that was
you